alexa
turn off the lights
okay
alexa turn on the lights
okay
today on chalk radio robots and humans
become collaborative partners
it's not about let's build machines that
look like people and act like people
it's let's build machines that dovetail
with us in a way that we can bring forth
all of ourselves to help us achieve the
goals that are really important to us
i'm your host sarah hansen
this week we're talking with a
researcher and educator who's working to
bridge the gap between human well-being
and artificial intelligence
from kindergarten to college classrooms
she's preparing the next generation of
informed technology users and empathetic
designers
i'm cynthia brazil i'm a professor at
mit at the media lab
i'm also director of a new mit wide
initiative
called responsible ai for social
empowerment and education we call it
raise for short
and i very recently am the dean for
digital learning
cynthia's fascination with artificial
intelligence began a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away
when i was 10 i saw star wars and
that forever shaped my
i guess vision of what a robot could be
for us i mean it wasn't just a mindless
automaton it was an entity that had you
know in the movie like they were
full-fledged characters right they had
friendships they were mission driven to
save the universe i mean all of that and
of course they had relationships not
just with you know the robots but with
people
cynthia followed that vision of complex
human-machine relationships all the way
to a phd program at mit
there she designed kismet the world's
first social robot
that kind of started this whole question
of socially and emotionally intelligent
interaction with machines because we
are profoundly socially and emotional
creatures if we want design technologies
that can interact with us and treat us
again as people we need to understand
that dimension
you know a lot of the early work was
pushing on i would say the algorithmic
side of that we looked at a lot of
models of emotion and people and animals
and like what is the function of it and
how might you implement aspects of that
for intelligent communication and
interaction with machines
and then we started thinking about okay
so what's this really good for so it's
fascinating you know from a scientific
perspective it's fascinating from a
technical perspective
but what does this mean about how
we will interact with
robots with intelligent machines in our
lives in our future and so then we
started thinking about so what are what
are these big societal challenges that
we face where
potentially an ai cut more from this
kind of cloth or this philosophy might
really make a difference
after kismet cynthia began working on a
new social robot named gebo
gebo is actually these concentric
rotating circles that are kind of off
axis
and with that he can kind of
create what's called an animational line
of action so he can change his posture
right so he can look like he's upright
or he can like stoop over or lean to the
side and [ __ ] his head like he can go
through all of these kind of expressive
postures that are
really foundational to an animator when
they want to express something through
characters
technologies tend to move in rectilinear
trajectories
living things move in arcs
and so all of gebo's motions was based
on arcs right so he naturally moved in a
way that she seemed much more lifelike
and expressive because he fundamentally
was designed to move in arcs you have to
see gebo move you have to actually watch
him dance because like he's like it's
incredible to watch this robot dance
gebo didn't just look and move
differently from other robots he
functioned differently too
i often use the language of there's like
the
digital assistant like this is what like
google and like they're all called
digital assistants and they're kind of
modeled after the executive assistant
we talk about jib as being a helpful
companion
so that speaks more to the social
emotional the relational aspects of it
but jibo is also helpful right he can
actually do things
but it's the way he does things are much
more
humanistic i would say human centered in
its design less transactional you know
the way he expresses himself through
movement and also just the language he
uses
it's much more
warm i would say like there's cool tech
jima was warm tech
[Music]
one exciting new application for jibo
that's currently being explored
is how he might help provide mental
health care
one of the studies we did we we
literally designed a emotional wellness
coach skill
for gebo and we deployed jivo in mit
student dorms because as you probably
know mental health is like a huge issue
i mean even before the pandemic
mental health emotional wellness of
students at a lot of top colleges was
like really concerning
so we decided to explore whether gebo as
an emotional wellness coach could
actually help
mitigate the stress and anxiety that
students experience when they're at a
you know an elite university like mit
so we developed some best in breed
therapeutic interactions that typically
a human would do like a coach would do
with their client or whatever right so
typically it's human human
we took these proven methods and we just
now gebo was just doing it with the
person and you know we published that
work and basically the punchline is we
were able to show that yeah jebos seemed
to make a positive difference so in
terms of the future of health right
people could go into hospitals
potentially and get you know world
quality care but what happens when they
go home
so again something like ajibo or social
robot or whatever the idea that they can
extend the quality of care and support
from the doctors and nurses in the
hospital to the home where patients are
living every day
that's a huge unmet need
and that's a role where potentially i
think an intelligent
kind of again collaborative allied agent
with this different kind of interaction
paradigm could make a big difference
one of the fascinating design decisions
behind jibo was choosing just how human
to make him
when we
developed g-bow we
were very intentional in saying there's
the character of gebo
when you talk about
the perception of how
children or adults perceive these agents
jibo was what you know as the character
was very aware that jibo was a robot and
you know if you tried to ask jibo things
that really a robot would have no
business answering like things around
religion or whatnot like jeeba would say
this like hey i'm just a robot you know
it's probably something that'd be good
to talk about another person with but
like
i'm just a robot so jiba was very
upfront and like transparent about his
robotness
collaborative allied agents like gebo
have huge potential to improve the lives
of humans
but as cynthia pointed out they can't
replace the power of real human social
networks
this gets into the ethics and the
responsible design of these things i
think
first and foremost
people need people we need
our human social networks are in person
caring human social networks to come
around us when we're in trouble
social media companies that will try to
tell you like your network of 5000
people you don't know is just as
important as your actual like real
in-person relationships
real in-person relationships are
absolutely essential they're essential
for our well-being
they're essential for children's
development i mean they're just critical
and so
it signals i think we're living in this
time when
people's time and attention has become
like this incredibly precious resource
where the fact that someone will stop
and take that time out for you
signals something of like you're you're
valued you are really valued and you're
you're meaningful
as a parent the importance of real
social networks for children really
feels true to me
but i also know that my child is growing
up in a world where digital interactions
are becoming more and more common and
potentially fraught with ethical
implications
so i shared with cynthia a recording of
my child talking with our home executive
assistant
alexa what's your favorite
color i like ultra violet
it glows with everything
and here's another fun fact about me
if you'd like i can learn your voice to
do all sorts of neat things like
greeting you by name
you'll need your own profile i can
create one for you now
what's your name
alexa off
i'll create a new profile
and send information about alexa terms
and our privacy notice to your app
should i go ahead and create a profile
with the name off alexa off
yeah so
as illustrated by that that clip
kids are growing up
in a time when they will have always
been able to talk and interact with
intelligent machines and not just you
know in this verbal way that we heard in
the clip but
hidden ways right so
when you're on social media and it's
trying to
learn your kind of what your preferences
are and giving you recommendations that
are not trying to
broaden your perspective but if anything
narrow and narrow and narrow narrow
or you know of course what we're
learning is what gets your attention
what tends to get shared
things that really upset you
you know those are the things that
really you know so that's what it tends
to feed you
surprisingly quickly right you know so
it's important for people of all ages
but i think it's important for kids
because like
the average age of when kids get their
first smartphone right it's like 10
years old right
and
social interaction
through technology becomes
such a
key way
they interact with each other so the
digital mediated communication is it
just becomes such an important way for
them to
connect and express themselves
and
just understanding
what's under the hood
how it could be
biasing you know shaping
their attitudes
potentially shaping behaviors this is
what's really critical and you know and
why who's doing it and why
that's where raise comes in
raise which stands for responsible ai
for social empowerment and education is
an mit initiative focused on exactly
these kinds of questions
it's kind of the cross-section of a.i
and
learning a.i and education so how can we
develop ai systems that help us learn
as well as how can we
understand how to best empower people to
learn about ai
so that they can be informed citizens
and how they use these technologies and
how do we cultivate the future designers
of these technologies that are
responsible and ethical in the designs
but also a far more diverse
and inclusive future workforce we love
to position the student as the designer
of these technologies so as the active
person who's thinking about the design
the social implications the goals all of
that
you know it really empowers students in
a way that they
they lean in and discuss and and are
invested in it i think you want children
to grow up
students who grow up with you know the
attitude that i actually can shape these
things you know this is a world that i
can be in and belong in and shape
we have both the research kind of
objective we have a
outreach like k-12 outreach objective
and a lot of that is bringing these
materials to teachers and students of
underrepresented under-resourced schools
and communities because
the field is not diverse or inclusive we
we need to take action to correct that
and so we have an explicit diversity and
inclusion mission in what we're doing
through the outreach and we are trying
to design these you know the curriculum
the concepts the activities
to meet students where they are and
things that they use and they think
about so it's super
relevant to them now but then we also
expose them to the way ai is
transforming so many
disciplines and markets and industries
so they understand like it's here and
it's going to continue to shape our
futures part of that work involves
offering an opportunity for young people
and their teachers across the country to
participate in the upcoming day of ai on
may 13 2022
we develop all kinds of
curriculum of different formats and
different lengths
so dave ai is the introductory
experience and it's really
an opportunity if teachers or students
are just curious about ai
it is literally a program intended to be
for
any kind of teacher
from students from elementary up to high
school
where
they can learn about
ai from more of the lens of
its implications on digital literacy and
digital citizenship but also
demystifying it as well so
all grade bands kind of have this what
is ai introductory module
so for instance like when i spoke about
this ai and creativity curriculum you
know we've had students who are saying
like i didn't think ai was relevant or
important to me because i want to be a
photographer when i grow up but they're
like now i realize wow like ai could
actually be a really cool tool that i
can use creatively in my profession of
photography when i grow up so a lot of
this just to help kids to understand
that chances are
this is something it's going to be
empowering and relevant to you
so just be aware of it being able to
leverage it to help you achieve your
goals and your your ambitions in life
well if there's a teacher out there like
me who sometimes can't even get her
agent to turn the lights on is this
still appropriate
absolutely so it's for all kinds of
teachers right this is not a
technical computer science stem
curriculum at all it's really much more
around again digital citizenship and
digital literacy as it pertains to ai so
again ai in our lives and understanding
that and you know having conversations
about that and designing some cool
things around that
yeah
so where can teachers go to sign up and
is there a fee associated so it's it's
free again one of the great things about
mit is we want to
lower the barrier as much as humanly
possible so all the materials are free
you can go to
dayofai.org
you can
look at the curriculum right there we
also offer free teacher training you can
register and you can sign up
for a online training session we are
collaborating with itu learning this is
a company that what they do is train
teachers this is what they do and so
we've worked with them to take our
curricular materials you know and
using kind of their experience to really
tune it for what they think is is great
for again a broad general teacher
audience and they are running the
teacher training sessions and again it's
it's completely free
so we would love for teachers to sign up
we are in almost all 50 states now
raise and the day of ai are increasing
access to ai education
and they're also informing how we teach
it
it is an open question still about what
are the most effective ways of
educating students at variety of ages
and backgrounds about what artificial
intelligence is
and how it works we still have much we
need to understand in terms of what
grades what preparation what concepts
how can we demystify
ai and these computational methods in a
way that's great and age-appropriate how
we can prepare teachers there's a whole
bunch of research questions there what
are the right approaches
methods of professional development for
teachers who i mean i can tell you they
didn't major in ai
in college right so this is new to them
too so how do we do that effectively
what are the longer impacts of this in
terms of
attitudes and dispositions that students
may form about these technologies and
about kind of themselves and their
relationship to these technologies
and then as we do this you know how do
we again holistically develop the whole
person as well so teamwork collaboration
communication critical thinking creative
you know they all are they can all be
kind of woven into this tapestry of how
we try to address ai literacy
through positioning students as the
designers and creators and makers of the
solutions with these technologies
so
we
design these activities and then we
evaluate them right so we will reach out
and recruit
students and teachers and we will engage
them we often engage in co-design with
them so even as we're developing these
materials we will work with teachers and
students as we develop them to make sure
that
they're you know effective in responding
and engaging
and then we go do rigorous
of
what are they understanding or not
understanding what is their pathway to
understanding and what is the
implication of that for how we think
about staging these concepts and ideas
are we seeing evidence that they are
developing dispositions about ai that
are empowering for them or do they find
it as being intimidating or not for them
right so there's a lot of questions that
we're trying to assess
and then when we have something we think
is solid you know then we
we make it available for free it's all
creative commons we're like our goal is
just
to help empower teachers
non-profits you know like get these
materials out there and share them
freely
but again no matter how good robots or
ai get
they're no replacement for the real
thing
i think a lot of ai has assumed when
you're trying to build these social and
emotional qualities into technology it's
about the robot
and i'm like no it's about the people
because this is what people need to
engage the more deeply we can engage
of our holistic self not just our
cognitive selves but our social selves
our emotional selves our physical self
so more deeply we can engage not
surprisingly the more successful we are
the better our outcome so it's to say
it's not about let's build machines that
look like people and act like people
it's let's build machines that dovetail
with us in a way that we can bring forth
all of ourselves to help us achieve the
goals that are really important to us
this is why i like when we talk about
ai as pedagogical agents right i'm like
we will never get rid of human teachers
because
they are essential for children to know
that in this community of human beings
adults
invest their time
in children's learning and development
like you matter i'm taking time and
energy to do this because it's that
important and you are that important
yeah you just can't underestimate that
[Music]
to take part in the day of ai on may
13th go to
dayofai.org
you can access free teacher training and
other creative commons educational
materials at raise.mit.edu
or you can access them through our
website at ocw.mit.edu
you can also find cynthia's free and
open teaching materials from our mit
courses on our website
thank you so much for listening
until next time signing off from a
galaxy not too far away i'm sarah hansen
from mit opencourseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
red pachy and dave lashansky
scriptwriting assistance from aubry
callaway
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
the rey's online publication was shared
on mit open courseware by sharon lin
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you